Let me show you, how we're going to be using Developer tools
in this course. I'm running Chrome Canary. And I have my
phone connected. Which I have just on the side here with
me. You can see that I have the udacity side open. Let's
inspect that. With the Developers tool's open, let's navigate to the
Timeline tab. This is where we're going to be spending most of our
time, in this course. Next, you can actually enable, the Screencast
feature, if you have your phone connected. So let's click, on that.
And you can see a preview of. What's actually
on my screen. And as you can see, it's the
same picture. To record a trace, we're just going to
hit reload and, wait for Chrome to capture the full
trace. Once the page is done, we have the
full trace here. And you can extend and view all
of the activity, here as well. This is the view
that we're going to be using for, most of the course.
>> Wow, that's pretty awesome.
But what if I don't have a phone handy?
>> I definitely recommend using Mobile Debugging if you
have a phone handy. But if you don't, you
can record the same Timeline data, directly on your
computer. Check the instructor notes, for a quick how-to.